women that get IVF are selfish
without a husband where they just get in
vitro fertilization and just have a kid
on their own and choose to be a single
mother
no
but that does affect the child
you don't think they're selfish why
because I mean let's say let's say like
you're a lesbian couple
okay okay
I'm not talking about lesbian couples
I'm talking about single mothers oh
I think even single mothers can have
people in their lives who's an effective
role model for the child so I don't
think it necessarily means oh they're
selfish and I feel like you don't think
it's selfish to put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage you possibly
could a statistic is a statistic it
doesn't mean it's gonna happen but if
they come around the people with the if
they if they're in a growing and growing
up in a home that's loving they have
good Role Models around them good
education they're less likely to be part
of that statistic so it depends on what
you're around and what you grow up with
if this is a single mother who's giving
her child the best education the best
role models all of those things their
less likely to be part of their
statistics and most women who are
getting IVF which they're paying for are
going to be ones that are more well off
that can do that for their children
would you say that
wait so you think because of money that
replaces the dad no no I said they're
more likely to have like these
statistics to do with socioeconomic
profiles as well of single mother
households no I mean you see like like
kids from single mother households go
shoot up a school like it's not
necessarily like you're equating like
men to money
it's got nothing to do with money it's
it's purely based on morals and
principles and the Dynamics of a male
and a female we have our roles and the
the father imputes his masculine role
onto his son and onto his daughter the
daughter grows up in reverence of a man
in respect and in love and in submission
without that you can see what's
happening in today's worldness as they
say women walk are walking around say
they don't need men and it's most likely
because they've never had a man to love
and not want anything in return I.E the
father
I think it really depends on I think or
any situation you come from the outcome
you decide to have from it depends on
your own motivation there's boys that
have come from homes with that are
single families and turn out to be the
most amazing
yeah that goes for everything in life
you can have a kid who's growing up in
the worst in the world and really bad
poverty and be one of the top in his
school or you can have a kid that went
to private school and not do anything
look I grew up in from a single mother
with five children on a counselor state
in South London I should have been a
statistic right I should have been and
trust me I was around drugs I was around
violence I was a lot of people that I
know went to prison my family went to
prison
we I grew up in a place you know that
wasn't too good but I turned out like
this I never I haven't been in trouble
with the police I haven't been to prison
I haven't been to jail do you know I
mean I'm living my life relatively
normal
but I would be the exception to the rule
and normally uh but just because I have
this story it doesn't mean that the
statistics that I read don't exist
but so I'm acknowledging the fact that
I'm the exception to the rule but I'm
also acknowledging that
the other things exist in the majority
so so this is one of the things that
people generally tend to do there gen
and even me knowing that I'm the
exception I still don't argue the
exception because I lived on the this
estate that I lived on and I saw all the
other guys go down the other route so I
knew that I was the anomaly you know
what I mean so that exists to me so I
could say oh I made it out but that
doesn't mean that that doesn't exist and
would you have preferred to have a
father there 100 and and that's like
like because to me if if you're choosing
to put your kid in a situation where you
know they're going to want to Dad and
they're going to ask these questions
like you're kind of thinking about what
you want over your kid is absolutely
selfish is the fact that they've played
the the short game long they thought
they can live a life that's conducive to
themselves at that time
and at the end of it still have their
cake in here and what I mean by that is
a lot of women that end up in that
situation are are women who are
literally unmarriageable because the
more the market dictates who who you
take because we men decide how the
sexual Dynamic Works women decide to
have sex and many decides who remarry so
if these women as a consequence of the
action become unmarriageable
what they're essentially doing is trying
to have their cake in here by going
through these ivfs and leaving their
child at a statistical disadvantage just
because they wanted to live the life
they wanted without consequence it's
most definitely selfish and there's no
question about it and the way people are
are so Brazen in justifying Madness is
is stupid to me I mean like I said
fatherlessness we just heard um what's
your name again Andy you just heard his
story you know Andy's story is a million
men story do you know I mean five
million men story so for women to choose
not to
um
to to choose to have children without a
father to me it's very selfish and not
just men women like I'm I'm pretty sure
that over 80 if not the vast majority
are strippers have either no father yeah
or absolutely terrible relations with
their father and I will go against the
Green and say they have no father
because if they did or have a father at
best Brothers
um
we know as men how we view how how we
how women can be objectified no man
wants that for his loved sister no man
wants that for his any woman in his
family
so
it makes sense to me as to why these
situations pan out there is a lack of
masculine figure in these people's lives
the the a lot of the women a lot of
women young women these days who are at
the most promiscuous high are selling
themselves short because they don't know
in the long run men are not going to
want them and not only that they can
hide they can go to a different city
because we spoke we spoke about this
previously they can move but it goes to
show your disciplining character when
you devalue yourself in such a way and
at the end of it there's going to be a
consequence because the ultimate game
and the ultimate goal for every woman is
to be in a long-term relationship some
so some way marriage or at least a
committed monogamy relationship
the statistics show it and We Know It by
biology sense but what they fail to
realize is the means of getting it they
don't know that it takes just as a man I
know what it takes to get a girl and
over the years I'm married well over the
years I know I've known and I we know
this from the day we're born we have to
become something otherwise you're not
getting recognized but women don't know
what it takes to obtain a relationship
because everything has been given to
them from the beginning
and then and then we have this you know
this Boss [ __ ] Mantra where you know
you can we don't men don't want that in
by and large and the men who do want it
you don't want them anyway we're going
to get back to this power we gotta get
to the super chat today so I have um
some super chats guys make sure you like
the video the like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
this content so make sure you like the
video um we all work hard here so like
is free come on also all of these um all
these super chats are going towards a
new camera and we want to get blessing
you want to shoot him what is it 8K
I can't hear you I can't hear you
all right
all right he said okay
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible